thank you very much um thank you for
sticking around you must share my
passion for this topic of legal
knowledge bases um or else you're just
waiting for the bar to open later on but
either way glad you're still here um
interested you're actually interested
okay so my name is Mike paulshock I am a
legal knowledge engineer um which is
kind of a combination of a lawyer and a
programmer um uh I work for a small
software consulting company called the
exitor group uh it's based in Boston we
build um the main product we build at
the moment are health exchanges so
you've heard of healthcare.gov we didn't
do that one but we do some of the state
based exchanges um so essentially what I
do is I build systems that automate the
law uh and
policy so what does that mean uh
basically involves looking at legal
source materials like regulations
statutes uh case law policy documents
and taking the rules that are in there
and turning it into computer code of
some kind uh and the idea is that once
you have done that then you can apply
the rules to different fact patterns
different cases and I'll give you a lot
of examples of that um the end the end
goal is you get uh determination or a
conclusion
right and then you take that
little base of knowledge and you embed
it in some sort of larger Software
System okay so there's a lot of
vocabulary that's kind of associated
with this domain expert systems is what
they called it in the 80s but then um
after art artificial intelligence kind
of let people down they rename them
business Ro engines um so a knowledge
base in the way that I'm using it is not
necessarily a collection of text
documents but it's actually more a
collection of algorithms that are being
applied to a um particular set of facts
um and the process of creating those
algorithms from the normative rules it's
called knowledge engineering a lot of
times it involves working with a subject
matter expert to find out um how they
understand the domain taking that
knowledge and somehow representing it
computationally um it's also goes by
policy automation or policy modeling
decision support systems computational
law so all of these different kind of
phrases in my mind point to the same you
know essential activity which is
representing normative rules
computationally so that you can apply
them again and again as you know new
data comes in so I always like to see
examples of things to make it easy so um
let's just let me give you some examples
of different software products that have
computational knowledge built into them
to some level of complexity or another
right when people ask me what I do I
always ask if they've heard of Turbo Tax
because it's kind of the easiest way for
people to relate to this right someone
had to
take knowledge of the tax code and
somehow bake it into turbox turbox then
generates this interactive inter you it
collects information about you and what
what you've done over the last year and
it comes to determinations about how
much you owe and other it makes other
sorts of
characterizations so I don't I don't
work for this company but that's my
activity right I I take the law and I
bake it into systems like this um taxes
in general uh are kind
of the first industry that has found its
way um into to be computational IED in
the law because it's very numeric um
it's it's pretty
deterministic and the government needs
its money so they you know they they
make the process easy so here are some
property tax tax calculators um from the
European Union um sales
tax right complicated issue because you
have so many jurisdictions um then you
have excise and use taxes so for
different things that you buy different
tax rates apply um none of it is really
conceptually hard but there's just a lot
of data that all has to be made user
friendly so here are some examples of
software that does
that um healthcare.gov so this is more
along the lines of the kind of systems
I've been working on lately um so behind
healthcare.gov I don't know exactly what
technology they use to build it but
there are probably you know 3 or
5,000 rules that represent logic
from regulations statutes uh and you
know policy materials to help you figure
out if you're eligible for Medicaid if
you're eligible for you know health
insurance tax credits things like that
so you go through this interview and
then the system at the end gives you a
determination you can use that
information to uh you know make
decisions about your Healthcare
options okay another example of a
government website that has to
administer this you know complex body of
regulations Social Security
Administration um they try and get you
they try and collect your data online
somewhere behind this is some sort of
code that is um probably applying uh
federal regulations and making
determinations about
you here's an example from New Zealand
um if you want to get a visa to New
Zealand you fill out this Wizard and it
will you know compute your
eligibility
here's an example from the IRS I
actually worked on this project it's
called the interactive tax assistant um
there are about 15 or 20 tax law topics
that you can go to um go through the
interview and it you know will tell you
here I think I was asking uh do you need
to file a tax return it's kind of the
the starting
question uh you can find a number of
Child Support calcul out
there uh they come in apps or on
websites um many of you have probably
heard of Legal Zoom prepares documents
for you I'm not sure how much actual
computational knowledge is baked into
this
but you know on some
level there must be some knowledge of of
the applicable law built-in because they
needed to assemble documents for you
that are later reviewed by human beings
um paralegals
divorce software called we vorce um
again I'm not sure how much family law
is in this but you can imagine that in
the future someday um you know state
laws pertaining to uh divorces and
family situations could be embedded in
here um you can think of like the
workflow of
divorce here's an app I found online
someone modeled uh the European Union
collateral directive I don't know what
that is but I'd rather use this then
read you know the regulations to figure
it
out
and who would have thought that uh storm
water runoff regulations um could in
some level be automated but someone has
created an App so if you're building a
building there are helps you figure out
if you're in compliance with
that um so those are all you know
modern apps modern applications but this
whole concept goes back
you know to the early days so you can
think about all the Mainframe systems
that are out there in the world that
have some sort of knowledge of the law
encoded in them probably in cobal uh and
Grace Hopper who invented cobal one of
her motivations in coming up with the
language was to make the language easier
for business users to use so that they
could deal with um compliance problems
so that when the business rules changed
or the policy environment changed they
could change their
code so the idea of computational law
goes back you know quite a while
um and and here are the the basic
benefits to it one you get consistent
answers I mean we've all had the
experience of calling a call center and
getting different answers different
times well you know if you have a
computer program making the
determination it's going to be
consistent it's going to be
faster um it's probably going to be be
cost effective because you just need to
basically build the system and maintain
it you don't need to employ so many
humans to uh to train them to make sure
they know the law and to have them
administer
it uh it's auditable so when you use
these systems um ideally they will give
you a rationale for why they came to the
conclusion they came to and as a user
you can take that if you want to appeal
the decision or if you're you know the
the company or the a agcy administering
it you have a log of why you came to the
decision that you came
to um these systems can hold a lot of
you know a lot of knowledge about a
particular domain um more sometimes more
than um a single domain expert um can
remember off hand and they can be
updated as the Law
changes okay so that's the kind of
system that I'm talking about right
that's just laying the groundwork for
the main theme of this talk which is the
best practices for how you go about
building these systems and there's you
know there's no school that you can go
to um and really what I'm telling you
here is just based on mistakes that I've
made or mistakes that I've seen made um
and I have made a lot and I've seen a
lot made um and I think the first
mistake that I have seen made is that
when people think about these
systems they want to think about them
procedurally they want to think about
them in a stepbystep sort of way and
maybe it's because a lot of times you
need to collect information in an
interview which is a stepbystep kind of
process so then people think okay how am
I going to represent the law is kind of
like in a stepbystep flow charty sort of
way um in order to build this um it's
much better if you can represent the law
in a declarative way where you're coming
to a conclusion if certain conditions
apply um because policy rules and legal
rules tend to be expressed in a
declarative
format um they they are generally not
expressed
procedurally um and procedural
representations such as flowcharts they
don't scale so if you have an app that
has five or 10 inputs sure you can
represent it as a flowchart that's not a
problem
you know when you have an app that has
300 inputs that's going to be a
flowchart that's you can't maintain so
just to emphasize the difference in the
two approaches on the left laser pointer
okay here's a flowchart procedural
representation and on the right here are
two examples of um declarative
representation so here's sort of a
natural
language uh way of expressing it and
here's more of a Codi way of expressing
this idea of a rule okay so these
systems are just a lot of these rules
all snap together in some uh giant
computational
environment okay so the first best
practice is to take um a declarative
approach the second
one in the academic literature it's
called
isomorphism Uh the basic idea is that
the code that you write should be
structured similarly to the rules that
you're
representing so that you can look at the
regulation and you can look at your code
and there's a onetoone correspondence
between the two right so you can look at
a provision of Law and say oh okay in my
code that maps to that so that way if uh
someone wants to verify it they can
compare both side to side if they you
know understand the syntax that you're
using to represent the logic and it's
easier to maintain because the law is
going to change when it changes you need
to know what where the code has to
change um so the closer that you can get
the two um to be to be structured the
better off you are so here's an example
of part of the code of federal
regulations and here's just a little you
know snippet of logic that might capture
part of what's in there so the waiver of
inadmissibility under this provision is
valid if you know these conditions apply
so you know what you want to do is use
the domain vocabulary you know the words
that are used in the regulation uh you
want to try to have your code reflect
that you want to use the same document
structure so legal rules uh are
organized statutes and regulations
hierarchically so to the degree that
your code can reflect that structure
it's going to be easier to to
maintain uh to the degree that you can
include citations to the original Source
material the better off you are so on a
lot of projects you know managers will
come to me and they'll say you know what
why did you write it this way or why did
your team do it this way what is the
source of Authority for this particular
rule if I can look at the code or look
at the documentation and say oh it's
from this provision you know in the
Vermont statutes
then you know they go back and
everyone's
happy um another thing is you're also
making assumptions as you convert the
law to code and so you want to document
document what those assumptions are um
and U you know other questions that you
have so that's the so that's isomorphism
right some sort of structural similarity
between uh the original policy and the
code so to to develop like this you
really need people with cross trained
you know with skill sets that cross each
other so either you need to start with
programmers you don't have to make them
lawyers but somehow make them familiar
and unafraid of legal materials or you
want to take people with legal
experience and train them in programming
in my experience the first is much
easier than the second um and also in my
experience people with a mathematics
background I find you know they pick it
up the quickest in general
so a lot of I've seen it called the
center of excellence approach where you
take people with both skill sets you
help them become sensitized to each
other's you know the knowledge each
other brings and then you have them work
together in a team to build these kinds
of
systems um and a critical component of
that is handling changes in the law so
you need some kind of process to monitor
the law as it changes have some kind of
workflow where you you know interpret
those
changes and you know figure out where
the code has to change and then document
that whole process for you know your own
internal auditability Pur
purposes um but fundamentally this is
programming um it's a programming
activity before I get to the next two uh
I just have to go into a little bit
about the tree likee structure of legal
rules so if you look at these rules the
top we're trying to figure out if the
person's liable for the tax that depends
on their income and whether they're a
dependent and then we have other rules
that prove those things right so you can
imagine that these all connect together
in you know a hierarchy a tree structure
and as you dig down into how you define
income and how you Define dependent the
tree gets deeper and deeper you know and
you just keep going until
you know you hit some sort of Common
Sense concept that your user can use or
until whatever system you're integrating
with has that piece of data okay so it
forms a big tree with at the top of it
is kind of the goal you want the system
to answer and at the bottom are the
inputs uh so what you need is a tool
that can deal with that tree because the
fundamental challenge is how does anyone
know what the inputs are for a
particular goal
and how do you know which of those
inputs are relevant for a particular
scenario um you know a lot of these
applications are interactive interviews
because as you start going through the
interview what is relevant changes
depending on your early answers and so
you need some way to dynamically collect
that
information um so whether it's for
debugging purposes or for a user to use
uh it just you need some way to take
that entire logical treat Tre structure
and you know collect the information in
an automated way
um so another part of that like every
you know every solution creates its own
problem well once you have a some sort
of system that can make use of that
tree uh then you have this automatically
generated interview but it's not
necessarily A Humane or empathetic
interview it's you know what the
software thinks should be collected next
so there's kind of this tension between
what the what you you know having the
interview be automatically generated
and um making it ask questions in a way
that will make sense to a human being
and so you really need to separate your
policy rules from any other rules that
are controlling the interview itself or
the user
experience um so you have all sorts of
rules about the sequence you have
message that me messages that are
appearing data transformation logic and
validation logic so all of that should
be kept separate from uh policy
rules okay my kind of one of my favorite
topics on the subject it has to do with
time right and in a lot of the uh
presentations that we've heard there
this kind of underlying underlying theme
of time and the complication that time
creates in Information Systems so in
these kinds of systems one issue is that
you know the laws are changing and the
system is going to have to deal with
that fact secondly the facts are
changing right someone's age is changing
over time their income is changing over
over
time um laws are often concerned with
the way things change over time so
you'll see Provisions like in the last
six months was it ever true for three of
those months that something was the case
right or over the last 10 calendar weeks
you know was something true
so you need you need logic that can
handle that sort of variability and
finally the points of time that you care
about may change so you may want a
determination today or maybe you want a
retroactive determination you know what
would have happened last month or maybe
you want to find out what might happen
in the future so all of these things
make time very complicated to model and
can result in very messy code unless you
think unless you plan in advance so you
really when you're looking at what
you're going to
model you you have you have to look at
sort of the temporal dimension of things
as you get started and I find it helpful
to think about you know a backdrop of
absolute time you know there's a
calendar in the background how do these
policies and how do the changing facts
fit onto this
calendar um and you know and you need
functions in your programming
environment that can deal with time and
temporal relations time series things
like
that uh the next best best practice I
would say is you really need the system
to be uh aware of what it doesn't
know um so expenses of whaling captains
is a little part of the tax law right
they get certain charitable deductions
so if you're building a system about
that are you g to ask someone if ask
someone if they're a whaling Captain you
know how deep into that are you going to
go you have to make these decisions but
a lot of times it's just not worth going
down into that level of detail because
they're probably only 200 whaling
captains you know subject to us tax law
um so there are all these questions
about granularity and the level of
detail um and you really need your
knowledge base to know what it doesn't
know so that if someone is a whaling
Captain you know that person will be
routed to a human for
processing
um
um eth you need a sufficiently
expressive language uh there are a lot
of business rule engines on the market
that really are not very expressive um
they try to get business users to write
code and so they don't have a lot of
functions uh they're not extendable and
they're also very expensive and I'm not
going to name names because there's a
video going on here um but I I prefer to
use some sort of functional programming
approach where you can really you know
you can build up a lot of sophisticated
um inferences based on very modular
components
so you know you can think of it as like
the conservation of complexity right
there is complexity in the regul ation
and it is not going away and if your
language can't handle that complexity
whatever system you're integrating with
will then have to deal with the part
that you know your language couldn't
handle um but either way it has to be
handled
somewhere if you want to be able to make
you know sophisticated
determinations so then just general
software best practices I won't go into
them because they're not really specific
to this domain but functional
programming I've me that unit
testing um and refactoring which is kind
of like constantly cleaning up your code
and looking for ways to make things
simpler um I'm a strong advocate of
that so closing thoughts the law is
inherently complicated I mean we live in
a complicated Society the law is not
going to become
simpler um it's kind of fractalesque in
its shape you know you can you can can
just keep going deeper and deeper into
it and you know maybe there's no way
out um but it is more computational than
it first appears
because you know underlying a lot of the
the vagueness and ambiguity is just
sheer logic and to the degree that you
can capture that logic in some sort of
you know computational
environment computers can do the work of
figuring things out rather than people
so it's kind of like these
systems you know they build a wrapper or
an interface around the complexity of
the law and they hide all that
complexity from the public from the user
healthcare.gov I mean one way to look at
it is like a wrapper around the
complexity of the Affordable Care Act
which is about a thousand pages long so
whatever technical problems that website
has had are nothing compared with the
technical problems of having you know
300 Mill ion people each have to read a
thousand page statute right so these
systems just you know in the end they
make law accessible to people
um you know who who or otherwise may not
um have access to
it so thank you for sticking around
thank you for listening